you know I said the last forum I talk
a bit about what we're doing with online
learning and so forth but really the
impetus for what we're doing is that
we're building a brand new curriculum
that's going to go into effect in 2015
so that we're looking at all sorts of
models of learning and ways to enhance
learner experiences and so forth
and so clearly one of the things that
we're very interested in this flipping
to curriculum a lot and so we've got
four years for some students five years
of curriculum that we're going to put
together and what we want to do is
create standards that our faculty will
use in thinking about their in-class
activities but also things like videos
and so forth they will support those
in-class activities so what I'm going to
tell you a little bit about today is
actually how we're going to empower how
we are empowering our faculty to
generate instructional videos to
thinking using the flipping flipping the
classroom so you know unlike having
maybe three or four or five or six or
seven or eight courses to put on we're
talking about hundreds of these videos
it's faculty you're going to have to
generate so how do we make it accessible
for them as most of us know as faculty
members you don't want to travel too far
outside of your circle to be able to do
something like this you have to have a a
very staccato training regimen and you
have to make the facility available at
many hours so the faculty can go in
there and engage in it as they like so
I'll show you a little bit of how we're
doing this
and you know this is just again some of
the reasons that we're doing it to
support flipped classrooms to reduce the
amount of time in lecture and support it
with instructional videos but also to
create things like deep dives of not
foreknowledge for our students so that
if they get interested in something we
may have additional videos or they can
follow up and get more detail on that
give ities that are done in the
classroom I will say good and then I'll
explain this a little bit
or we are very very blessed at the
medical school because the library under
Kenny Murrow John Gallagher and with the
assistance of lay Wayne who happens to
be here as an instructional video
specialist have collaborated with us to
create a studio that our faculty can use
at any time that the library is open and
to create a training facility that our
faculty can engage in very easily so
this is just to show you a little bit of
some clips of the type of video that
we're generating so we want to make sure
that faculty can generate any number of
types of videos to support their
curriculum so not only that they can
create kind of Khan Academy style videos
but what if they have high resolution
images or if they have videos of an
operation or a surgery that they want to
embed in there we have to create the
facility that they can do that and do
that very easily so this is just
something from my course it just started
this week and I've taken snippets of
this it's really about a seven minute
long video and so you'll see black spots
where I've kind of cut this but to show
you a little bit of the types of things
that these faculty our faculty can
generate
On January 24th
we'll have my favorite lecture of the
year we'll talk about some anatomy
physiology and pathology then Alena
Hopkins will tell us her experiences
with hydrocephalus finally you'll do in
this topic surgery on green and red
peppers to retrieve their seeds I hope
you enjoy it let me give you a preview
in the lateral ventricle you'll see the
septum pellucidum choroid plexus foramen
of Monro we are descending through a six
millimeter tube into the ventricular
system
so the idea is these are things they're
gonna see in the in class we entering
some wonderful portals in aluminum it
nobody else using optic chiasm now we
are going to score the floor the third
ventricle with a YAG laser the heat at
the tip is very focal the laser tip is
0.8 millimeters
notice how the floor the third ventricle
shrinks now we need to perforate the
floor of the third ventricle and widen
the opening for this way using steel
forceps now I need to look through our
opening to make sure we are in a
subarachnoid location the basal artery
is very apparent so the point here is
that this faculty member wanted to be
able to show videos of the surgery he
wanted to be able to annotate over a
PowerPoint to point out nomenclature in
language and terminology and he wanted
to give the students the experience of
things that they're going to anticipate
in the in classics lecture hall so how
do you do this so and actually just to
show you in our pilot programs were
being fairly effective in terms of how
students engage in this so I put this up
about three days before the lecture we
monitored the the views of this in the
14 hour period before the lecture and of
a hundred medical students we had 68
views after the lecture in fact 23 more
people viewed the the material so again
I think showing not only that it was
important for their preparation for the
lecture but some of them felt it
valuable enough that they would come
back and look at it after the lecture
and I think a lot of our online kind of
idea is that we'll put these things up
students can engage in them when they're
going into the experience but they'll
use them as learning checks along the
way after they engage in in the lectures
and so forth so how are we providing the
resources
to do this so we're supporting faculty
and training and design you know tell
you a little bit about that we're using
a technology that is easy to use okay
and and very adaptable work helping them
to think is what what do they do to
create the optimal learning experience
for the learner okay how do you make
these things fit what the learners
experience is we're making sure that
they understand that you can't give
videos without telling the students what
your expectations are for how they're
going to use them in the classroom
there's a lot of places that have tried
to do flipping to cut the classroom
particularly medical schools and they
give the students videos and then
there's no appreciation of what happens
when they come in to the classroom what
what's the relationship of the video is
to the classroom experience so we're
helping train our faculty around that
and then also we're providing an
assessment within the video but not only
assessment within the video but the
faculty can view their student responses
on those assessments the night before
they come in to the classroom they can
then modify their in-class teaching
based upon those questions that the
students got correct and incorrect and
so forth so I think the idea this is to
be a very active learning experience for
both the student as well as for the
faculty this just shows you the flow
diagram of how we do this so the faculty
member comes in with the vision of what
they want to do it with their video okay
and I'll show you they engage with
people from the library simply a way
myself and others where we help them
refine that vision a little bit now
they're just gonna generate a video then
they would go we would help them
storyboard it a little bit Leia would
train them how to use the library
facility the fact is once they've done
this once or twice they can come in and
do it without any help by just checking
out the key at the circulation desk we
then help them understand how to edit
and splice films into these films and
other things we provide a little bit of
that for them but our hope is it once
they've done it five
six times they're able to end it fairly
easily we use a program called Camtasia
which is very intuitive and very easy to
use and then what happens is because we
want to standard for these videos
we're not letting people just put up
anything onto our instructional video
site so we don't want people to throw in
their their 60 minute lecture it happens
to be done this way so we're creating
standards for publication and I'll show
you a little bit of this in a second so
that at least initially we want the
students experience to be rather uniform
with these videos okay because if they
come and they watch a video that's too
long or not well enough done they may
not engage in those videos again for
other classes or for even that class
later on so it's important to create
expectations then also running while
we're training them in this our teaching
and learning center can help them
generate assessments to go into the
videos and it put them into the video we
actually put our assessments assessments
in in Qualtrics which is a survey monkey
like thing that the Yale University
licenses the beauty of that is the
faculty can access the reports very
easily at any time we also create a link
so that students can get feedback on how
the other students have done in
aggregate so they not only see what
their feedback is on the assessments
they can see what everybody else has
done we also provide cameras in in some
support for people who want to do
on-site videos like filming an interview
for example with the patient that would
then be spliced into these online videos
so that's the model this is how we do it
initial contact is with me or Leigh way
or or Gary lighting who's in our
teaching and learning center hopefully
in the future the me is out of there and
we find that we can do this better but
this is just a start late way in the
library and I have to say again it is
very important to have
partners in this and the library has
been an amazing partner in this one I
think if they see value to them as a as
a deliverer in curriculum and it creates
a lot of value for us and so lady works
with this all the faculty trains them
how to use the studio tells them how to
use Camtasia how to turn on the camera
how to use the computer how to kind of
storyboard their powerpoints he works
with them with the first few videos and
then the idea is that then they will
come back after that and do it on their
own we always work with a presentation
they want to use we don't do kind of
train you on something that doesn't mean
anything to you and so he trains them
once he feels comfortable that they know
how to use the booth he lets the
circulation desk know that those people
are can use the system and they can go
in and they can get the key and use that
system anytime they want we talked to
them about pedagogy obviously this is
the things that we're enforcing no video
can have more than two to four concepts
four to twenty minutes in length so a
maximum of 20 minutes in length we're
very lucky than another librarian to be
spec is advising our faculty on
copyright so you know when we stay
behind the Yale firewall we're kind of
okay right but if somehow if the
students start distributing this
material on their own we want to make
sure that we're at least in the you know
in the ballpark in terms of copyright
and so Judy's been an indispensable and
advising us on that the teaching
Learning Center Gary Lydon again
instructs back to be on in on the videos
for the exams or rather the exams for
the videos and then finally we have some
conversations around expectations
scheduling so they have to schedule that
first visit to talk about what their
ideas are and then Kathy castle on with
leg length does an online calendar which
allows faculty to know when the booth is
busy when it's open so they can schedule
in so we're now kind of in the phase of
getting those four
few brave souls to do this so Charlie
Duncan who wrote did the one you just
saw and others have done it and as we
move into more of these videos I'm going
around to every course director module
director clerkship director meeting
about twice a year and proselytizing and
the goal is that by the time we get to a
new curriculum in 2015 that this will be
something that people will be
comfortable with they'll be kind of
charged up about using it and we'll use
our curriculum committee to make sure
that we make good use of this these
videos in a flipped curriculum this is
just again to show you a little bit the
studio so it's a little bit bigger than
a broom closet
but not much so it doesn't take a lot of
room to do this this is the booth over
here so the library contracted to have
the sound proofing put down some
deadening materials put in we have a Mac
computer in which the PowerPoint can be
run or the videos if that information
there streams to a drawing tablet wake
them drawing tablet in front of the
faculty member they have a pen and they
can annotate on top of that and so forth
so there's a high quality microphone
that they use to speak into and if they
want to have a talking head they're
talking back there's a webcam on there
and Camtasia does film was talking head
which you can either cut in and move out
or move around in the frame or change in
size if you like I think we recommend
that our faculty only use a talking head
in the intro slide right because there's
nothing going on once you have
information going in in the slide and
you're annotating you don't want someone
looking at the face that's always moving
because if it tracks from they're
focusing on the material and then again
the other thing is we have video cameras
and sound equipment that they can check
out either from the library or are
teaching a Learning Center so if they
want to do some filming out you know in
the community or in their clinic or
whatever they they can come in bring
back that video and we can show them how
to edit
that in to the online video it's trivial
and works really well and then just to
show our interface so one of the things
we've learned it we're lucky because we
have a few students and we control all
the courses and there aren't all that
many courses is the we found that the
user interface is very important for
this so what our students don't like to
do is to go somewhere else and search
for something put in the keyword think
about the course so our user interfaces
it for each year as a and this happens
to be a test site and we're using it's
not the real site but as a course of
clerkship for elective makes videos we
create a tab for them ok and then the
student can hit that tab it takes them
to that site where the name of the video
is listed here
what lecture or course or small group
session it's going to be relative to and
some information on the video and so
that way it's very easy for them to
engage in the system what we have
learned over time is that if we use a
complex system that requires the
students to navigate it they all figure
it out so it's not like they're they
can't figure it out they're all Yale
students but what we're doing is we're
spending time do we want them to learn
one thing having them master something
else and the key is always in our mind
is make the interface so they don't have
to learn it make the interface so that's
the same for every course in their
reactivity and then finally this is what
the assessment reports look in Qualtrics
after they've been done so you know a
student would see their own responses on
and they're taking the test once they
submit it they hit back this report
which tells them in aggregate how all
the other students who took that before
them have done in addition this is the
report that the faculty member gets to
tell them not only you know what
percentage they they got for each
response and which ones which percentage
that the correct response with
percentage had each of the incorrect
responsive and so forth this is also
important for helping you to think about
how you continue to modify your videos
because if you think that you've taught
them something in 60% of them don't get
it after watching that short you know 4
to 15 minute video you haven't done
something very well you haven't asked
the question right or you haven't taught
the material right and so that's a
really important standards for us and
then I just finish up with this slide
here just to say these are what we
consider the big challenges in using
video content in a curriculum where's
the time come from to do this so as
we're thinking about our new curriculum
we're thinking how much of this would be
naturally expected kind of homework time
if you will and how much of it requires
us to lay aside time during the formal
curriculum for them to be able to view
this content and that's a hard question
there's a lot of really smart people
around the country thinking about this
but it is something we're trying to
solve before we get to our new
curriculum again how does the material
relate to the in-class activities what
are the standards that are appropriate
to enforce on faculty you don't want to
inhibit creative freedom you don't want
faculty to all be giving exactly the
same standard and and take away from
their freedom to teach in creative ways
but you do want to say what are the
standards that we're going to use maybe
length of time and so forth that are
appropriate I like this acronym wsq
watch summarizing question it is very
important that you teach the learner how
they watch movies because they watched
the Godfather very differently than they
do an instructional video where you want
them to take something away from it and
so in our new curriculum we will spend
some time instructing our students on
how do you engage in instructional
videos how do you think about your
experience and how do you when you're
done with it reflect on it to make sure
that you've learned something from that
experience copyright material finally we
built we're building web analytics into
the
these videos and surveys and focus
groups to try and think about how
effective is what we're doing in terms
of creating the environments of the
learner that enhances their learning and
this is just a show it's now expanded by
several courses and clerkships but this
was the initial group of courses in
clerkship it started to play with this
in a way with some sessions in this year
and we're hoping this will expand the
Cure dramatically so that's it thank you